I was on cloud nine I go play in the
Cape Cod League this is It's All Coming
to fruition my elbow starts acting real
feeling very strange I ended up having
Tommy John
struggling with the recovery never
returned to full speed and for whatever
reason I had another intuitive feeling
about just dabbling with some music and
I just I just had some call into it I
self-taught myself some garage man I
made a few songs and for whatever reason
like the first one I put out went viral
so when did you graduate
um 2007 was the year my freshman year I
had the all that was like my my breakout
year 2007. so I graduated 2012 and then
I did Georgetown grad for for half so
like the same time that you were in
college I was in college basically okay
yeah
it was you
um
Asher Roth right was another one and
then there was um Mac Miller yeah and I
went to school in Pennsylvania and Asher
Roth and Mac Miller were just [__]
running back and forth across the stage
doing every frat house whatever yeah and
uh so I remember listening a little bit
whatever and then when strowman uh my
brother and I he started damning
something about [__] like yo what
coins to buy yeah
there was like a six months stretch he's
like literally every day was like yo bro
where would I put the cash that's my guy
and so then and then he kept like
tweeting at you or whatever and then I
was like oh wait a second
and I started listening I was like oh
[__] yeah he literally went all in all
this [__] awesome yeah it went all in
I mean the guys you mentioned
[__] man like uh especially Mac Miller
rest in peace I remember
I remember just
just starting to dabble a little bit in
my room making because I because I was
injured really what happened was you
know I was you recorded
my full-time my and since I was [__]
eight years old I was just I had this
very intuitive draw towards baseball
knew it would be my meal ticket out of
where I live you know just knew it would
be that was the thing yeah it was and I
knew I had it I had something I was from
Rhode Island so it's not a baseball
Powerhouse by any means so the whole
time there was that like you know
neighborhood like I was really good in
this area but what does it mean you know
and I I worked very hard very diligently
I had a great
super lucky with a great family great
father helped [__] sorry helped
cultivate you know my my skills whatever
I go on to play at Duke
um which was you know already kind of
feel like I was achieving my dream and
first year I just had as I look back
um almost like every single thing went
my way that year I was a All-American as
a freshman closer just like I remember
throwing balls 2-0 right down the
[__] middle and it just they just
roll over it was just like the whole
year yes I was I was you know excelling
but I just remember now that I have some
hindsight like a lot of [__] went my way
it was almost like the universe was
giving me like it's your last hurray you
know what I mean because it's like
really what happened man like I was on
cloud nine I go play in the Cape Cod
League this is It's All Coming to
fruition my elbow starts acting real
feeling very strange I was a guy who's
like never hurt yep I never came out of
a game when I pitched in high school
just always my arm never hurt I was and
then all and it just changed like one
day ended up having Tommy John
struggling with the recovery never
returned to full speed and for whatever
reason I had another intuitive feeling
about just dabbling with some music you
know because he had never made music
never never that's crazy strange and
like I don't know what the [__] it was
really I mean I
I I guess I was the guy who could like
Freestyle while everyone was drunk on
the baseball team and I could do it you
know but nothing nothing like wow you
need to do this you know like yeah yeah
and I just I just had some calling to it
I self-taught myself from GarageBand I
made a few songs
and for whatever reason like relatively
relatively the first one I put out went
viral my buddy came and shot it for free
he's like y'all like this like I thought
it was just going to be my one and done
music video like I made one and this is
you know I remember this like the whole
time I'm thinking I'm gonna be a
professional baseball player this is
just a bump in the road I'm gonna be
better
and it just uh it just totally went a
different direction I I kind of got
enthralled by it I kind of had an aha
moment when I was like trying really
trying to recover and it wasn't
happening and I'm traveling I'm going to
the games and I'm like you know it sucks
because I kind of was the guy freshman
year and now I'm watching my peers kind
of play and I'm sitting there and
the fans I started having fans in the in
the crowd like where they'd be like Mike
Stud fans like yo my I had like one song
two songs out and my wheels started
turning on the other musician he
actually plays baseball as his hobby
yeah and it's they kind of supplement
each other because I feel like that's
the reason people cared about the music
really like it was amateur and cool but
they were like oh he's a [__]
baseball player that's kind of cool like
you know it's not bad it's you know but
I started my wheels started turning a
little bit not that I felt like it would
be my career per se but it just felt
like it was the next step for me it was
almost like pay attention to the signs
like you got fans here from University
of Louisville while you're playing them
and they know you for you know one music
one thing I I spent like one week doing
it with the with the kids in the Dugout
or like the coaches were they like yeah
what's going on here or they think it
was cool they didn't even the the guys
on the team just thought it was a laugh
like you know once it started to work a
little bit and pop they were supportive
to my face you know my good buddies were
like yeah but but no one like I'd be
totally lying if I said that anyone
really thought it would translate into
you know the life that we've gone on to
lead and just have how it became really
what I am and what I do and my I feel as
though it's my place right now and I
feel like I'm right where I should be
you know but so when you started
recording how much of it was like I'm
just gonna record a certain way because
that's all I can do like I don't have
access to a big Studio I don't have you
know producer or whatever it was just
more of like well [__] it like if I'm
gonna do this in any serious way I just
got to do with what I have at the moment
yeah I mean
I was like uh I I think I got a Mac like
my junior year in college like I wasn't
even one of those guys with a laugh like
I got it there was GarageBand on there
and I just had free time man my
roommates were baseball players they
were gone like I wasn't traveling with
the team so you know I kind of always
had a way with words so I like just I
just had this inclination to do it man I
can't really put a finger on what made
me do it exactly
but at the same time I feel as though in
hindsight and how I'm living my life now
it's just like that's what it is man
following your intuition yeah you got a
feeling about something go X go go after
it you know it's so funny because I
think now for those that don't know uh
the way you create the music is very
different the way that you've marketed
music is very different I think the way
that you uh live your life and like the
business behind it will get in all this
it's just like you've approached it very
differently but if you even go back and
you listen the Jay-Z's of the world or
the Dame dashes they'll say the same
thing they're like yo we wanted a record
deal we just couldn't get one so then we
had to do it ourselves if we wanted to
chase this thing yeah how much of it for
you was that in the beginning and then
when did it change when were you like no
actually even if a record deal shows up
like I don't want that yeah right yeah I
want to do it this other way because
like I'm assuming that changes at some
point yeah and you're like no this is my
path I'm a double down absolutely yeah
you hit now on the head man I think you
do it I did it first off I made these
songs if I had to go to a studio to make
those songs that would have never
existed I would have never did it you
know
um
and you know I make a few songs it
starts to work
I take a leap of faith I start touring a
little bit you know I definitely had a
bit of beginner's luck you know [__] was
kind of going my way like
it was a very different landscape you
know like there was there was a handful
of artists like you just put your finger
like oh Astra Roth Matt it was a few of
them look at nowadays there's literally
hundreds of thousands of artists people
making music and and sharing it when and
this era was like this perfect time
where but it was also it was like
there's only a couple of people who are
doing it but the people I just named it
almost felt like they were targeting the
college Market yeah well right it was
like kind of like the Frat houses
called coin frat wrap like it was like
kids in college College age not like
um it was just a totally different
Sphere for for hip-hop where it didn't
really exist where it's like friendlier
hip-hop what are college kids really
experiencing for the most part it's a
lot different than regular hip-hop
culture experiences so it was just kind
of speaking to a lot of kids who like
hip-hop but maybe the lyrics
were a more relatable coming from
somebody in the same age group that's
had similar life experiences so it kind
of
it kind of
dialed into that like a relatability you
might like hip-hop in the way it makes
you feel but even here's some hip-hop
that maybe you can relate to so it was
it was kind of geared towards yeah
college kids but organically because
that's all we knew you know I mean so
you brought up Mac Miller I remember I
didn't even know that there was like
this kind of Internet rap thing
happening until I made a song and I put
one you know I saw Mac Miller I didn't
know he existed yet and I just I
remember watching him and I was just
like
and I and and I don't mean this in any
disrespect he's one of my favorite
artists I mean I just saw how he was
doing it he's walking around with his
friends he's talking about real life
[__] like that I could relate to and I
was just like I could do this it's kind
of like a light bulb went off and I
remember him specifically I remember the
video but you have to see it like like I
do think
um being exposed to things makes it
tangible right like you realize oh
somebody else didn't have to go to the
big Studio they didn't have to do the
really scripted music video just walked
around with their friends and like the
uh the ability to emulate comes from
exposure to it yeah and I do wonder how
like the internet obviously was
important right but also like this
entire generation like I remember when
we first got like YouTube and being like
yo crazy they would never put this [__]
on TV like that's how you thought about
internet videos right it was like this
is the cool stuff they would never put
this on TV now everyone's dropping TV to
go and basically okay YouTube right like
it's crazy how much that changes I think
it's an amazing time to be alive I mean
you can make arguments either which way
there's an argument for every everything
on the internet valid arguments on every
side of every topic you know but I think
it's an amazing time to be alive and
just being witness to what's happening
in the evolutions and and uh especially
in the Arts uh we could get into it more
like later in the conversation but I
it's just such an interesting time to be
a Creator and contributor how do you
make the music right now so you've got a
microphone you just got your computer
basically yeah and you get an idea you
just jump on the microphone yeah yeah I
mean
um
I can honestly say I think my first
setup was like
1200 bucks all in
you know and that was that song that one
song it was called college humor
talk you know and I was literally just
talking about my day in college that day
like it just just caught on enough you
know but I mean I was recording in a
Marcus strowman was there we were in a
closet I hung towels up to get a little
sound proofing or whatever and we're
just [__] just throwing paint against
it while having fun you know and like
truly that's what I've tried to harness
now that's what I'm doing right now I
was telling you before we got on screen
I mean my setup
uh is in front of the biggest nicest
window in the house usually
um ideally in the master bedroom so
that's how I'm choosing houses you know
essentially what I'm doing is I'm
traveling uh I'm I'm kind of like a
current day Gypsy in a sense like I I
don't have a permanent address when
covid really really happened in in 2020
I had been in La for about six years
I've done the whole Hollywood Race try
to be a cool guy Beverly Hills you know
and it just never aligned with me and I
just it was almost trying to fit a
square peg into a round hole I felt and
I also kind of developed into an artist
where I record myself I'm the lead
producer I'm lead vocalist I'm lead
engineer I'm executive producing and I'm
handing file exchanges to mix master I'm
handling the business I've stayed
independent where you know so it is it's
just not not a One-Stop shop I'll say
because I work with a few producers
mainly remotely but like I don't need to
be in [__] LA or Nashville I don't
need to be in a Music City and that
freedom that aha moment
I went and visited my buddy at the time
I was very close with post Malone and he
was around in La a bunch he's always
come over to the house and I went out to
see him in Utah and live live out there
for a while and I just
I just noticed how I felt man I was
waking up these pine trees and and how I
felt creatively and I just knew I needed
to go and we just sold and and [__]
picked up and left and we're U-Haul
Penske boys man like we we you know I
travel late I gotta I got one big
storage unit in Nashville one big
storage unit in La
um I have an amazing guy who takes care
and does the drives and helps break down
and makes moving easy you know but we're
light so it makes moving easy but we're
traveling wherever the [__] we're called
to you know so I've been in Miami for
two months right now I'm looking at a
you know I'm looking at the ocean and
and you can I I seriously like what I
will say creativity is is a bit of
there's some spirituality with being
creative and there are places there's
energy in everywhere you go 100 like it
will light you the [__] up and I've at
The more I've tuned into just being
present in spirit I'll say aligned with
my spirit I just realized and recognize
when a place has gotten stale or
stagnant and I would appreciate
something new whether it's the
electricity in Miami where you get that
vibe from the ocean the ocean's one of
the most energetic things on the [__]
planet like
um then there's Mountain I've been to
two different places in Montana uh Idaho
we've been all over you know all
different types of spaces and energy but
I I feel as though I'm I'm not really
I'm just tuning in to the to the space
that I'm at and I feel like I'm a vessel
I can translate it into the music I make
different music there than I would here
and I set up in front of big studios it
makes no sense to look at a wall if
you're trying to be creative imagine
going into the same room every day and
be like why are my ideas stagnant I'm
looking at this [__] black wall you
know what I mean and now I'm like oh I'm
looking at this beautiful view that I
haven't seen yet in this new house you
know that energy there's an excitement
to it and what it what it's done to me
is that just feels so
present because I'm not really letting
stagnation happen you know the way the
mind works I've dove into that a lot and
I just feel like I'm more or less trying
to live every day
in a Creator basically opening up a way
for me to feel creative and create space
for ideas to come through
much of the super viral super successful
songs are
hours days weeks of work versus like
yeah I was drunk and I just had an idea
and I [__] sat down recorded it it's
like the equivalent on Twitter I always
joke that like you know these people
will spend hours I've done it yo it's
the fire tweet
dud toilet tweet you're sitting there
taking a [__] bam fire went off super
viral right and like I don't know if
that's uh that's the truth like that
that's the thing that's closest to like
uh the authenticness and that resonates
with people and so it explodes is music
the same way yeah I have I have a
thought about like writing like
journaling or any writing ideas like if
it's if it's not messy you thought too
much about it and and I think creativity
what I was just saying is about I'm
basically trying to set up myself every
day to be available for ideas to come
when the ideas come you just be a vessel
and translate it so that's how I've made
it into my music making process
it varies right it's Case by case some
ideas might need to be nourished and
ushered into a certain space
personally
um I know in my experience all the best
stuff is in the magic the stuff that I
you know all my all my best stuff really
the majority of the idea happened in an
instant happened in a span of 10 20 30
minutes
um
and that's that's really where I lean
more and more as I go if I got to think
about it and baby an idea and like work
hard I've don't tried tattooed in my leg
but if I have to work hard to get this
idea to fruition
you know I mean I don't it might not it
kind of speaks to me like there's some I
don't know you know like the ones that I
get really excited about and feel and
the proof is in the results like a lot
of them are they're moments yeah moments
that you capture how um how much do you
pay attention to how big the audience is
how successful a song is like what I
would think of a business person goes to
work right and they're very much uh okay
we have to hit X Revenue goal we have to
uh you know recess many customers
whatever most creative people it's kind
of hit or miss some people are like that
right they're very data driven and very
much like hey I want to create things
that that keep growing my audience and
things like that other people are just
like bro I couldn't tell you how many
followers I have or whatever because
it's just like I'm just like I just
enjoy the music and if it works it works
great yeah
um
in my opinion it's about it's for the
artist right it's about the doing it's
just about the creation right I know
because I've been in the game for a
minute and I know and I've I've had so
many foots in the water hey I might dive
in do a record deal hey let's let's go
mainstream let's grow the audience
really what it is is they're offering a
commodity exchange we're going to give
you more Fame notoriety your name your
value your presence you'll be able to
monetize at a much higher level probably
10x maybe 20. Shake maybe 100 you know
you could be we could make you that
without us you're not going to be that
right and that's really the dream and
that's really the commodity exchange if
you think about it is we're going to
take the Lion's Share of the income here
on this music
we're going to take 85 the common deal
is 85 goes to the record label the
artist gets 15 but we're gonna grow you
and your presence so strong that the
return on on just your notoriety and
just your brand
um is is going to make more than enough
sense now that come that Rings true for
a tiny percent of artists who do record
deals and that's who they Champion to
the new kids they're trying to sign look
what we did yeah look look at post
Malone look at you know all these but
really the majority of artists that
doesn't happen and really what ends up
happening is you get shelved because art
it's a corporate game right like these
these are publicly traded companies
they want market share hey we got 75 of
market share this is why our valuation
is this it's going up and up and up they
want to gobble gobble gobble gobble up
the market share they don't care
personally about your record or your
career going to the Moon they want the
market you know what I mean so
in regards to audience
like I'll tell you really most of it is
smoke and mirrors I can say that like
factually right like they're paying
people to boost like they're paying
people to boost the streams I know
they're stream Farms I've seen it I've
been in email exchanges where like hey
we can offer you this and because really
what what they're feeding into is it's
the modern day marketing right it's just
it's the herd mentality
this has eight billion oh do you see
he's getting 75 000 likes on these
videos and all these comments like what
am I missing out over here you know that
song's got a billion streams or I can't
I can't swipe through Tick Tock and not
hear this song what is this song I
should know about it you know oh I do
like this yeah really that's what
they're feeding into but it's it's kind
of a big game of Paola you know what I
mean like if something's booming on Tick
Tock it's mainly because they spent a
bunch of money paying influencers to use
the records organically in their posts
how much you think they pay to make
something go viral I mean it ranges
right like you could pay a bunch of
money and your [__] sucks and it's not
gonna work I'm not I'm not taking away
from the artist but the game really is
like that's really become the new
commercial that's become the new radio
ad that's become the new you know like
it's it's essentially like hey
anywhere from probably it can range but
anywhere the starting point for really
getting some traction on tick tocks
probably 50k a song on the radio is a
hit song because they put almost a
million dollars behind it yeah getting
all the [__] I hearts and everybody
conglomerates and that's really the
whole game right so when you realize
that as the artist
you know like for me
it's corny to [__] pay people to like
my [__] I'm not interested in that
that's that's just lame you know what I
mean like so I just started seeing what
was actually happening you asked the
question earlier I don't even think I
got to the answer but it's like
there was a time where I wanted more
than anything to just be validated by a
record deal say hey look [__] you guys
you were wrong you know what I mean or
hey Mom like look I'm not an idiot I
want to Duke and I became a [__]
white college rapper and it's working
out I got a record deal like look at my
songs on the radio there was one time
where I did a little I did a distro deal
not a record deal but the distro deal
and this Legend leor Cohen who's a rap
Legend but you know just
administrative Legend in hip-hop [__]
with me came on board ran one of my
songs up this was 2014 like I'd a record
working at radio and I remember sitting
in my car like waiting for it to come on
in my local radio station you know I
mean now I look back at that and I
Grimace I'm just like really all it was
is just like I'm paying people to play
the music did it really the dream like
the way you have is like oh you get you
make such a great song that everyone
hears it where that's really not that's
just making a great song is your
artist's Duty and going back to your
main question here is like it's what it
has to be about if you want to be an
artist for a long time and enjoy
yourself if you're if you're attached to
the results when they're not even in
your control you have to do a deal or
you have to have private capital or you
have to figure out how to really hustle
move and Shake maybe you network your
ass off and you know a bunch of tick
tockers and they'll post it for you
because they're your boy or whatever it
is but there's external factors that are
out of your control roll completely in
regards to having a hit hey is saying
the regular guy you know whoever who's
not really in the music game Wow Mike
made it man like I hear a song on the
radio and like wow there's millions of
followers now and like look how big and
popular he is you know
that became less and less the goal as I
started to see the realities of what was
going on how much of like the lifestyle
the vibe right because it's very
distinct
um yeah I can pretty much play any one
of yours I don't know this but uh my
young daughter if I play one of the
songs she starts dancing right and is
like you Old MacDonald and a couple
other songs but like there's just
something to it right where no matter if
you're a young child or an adult like
you feel is different right
it's a magnet though because you have a
lot of friends a lot of people who have
come around you they professional
athletes people that others would know
that aren't in the music industry
whatever and is it more so they're drawn
to like hey this is different and uh
kind of the outlier type folks somehow
find each other in life yeah like I
think a lot about you know everyone
who's like super corporate if they go to
a party they all find each other and
they go and they talk in the corner
right and then all the action man yeah
like all the weirdos right they all end
up in a corner all the entrepreneurs end
up in a corner right all the people who
like are the contrarians they end up and
you're like how'd this happen how do we
self-select into these groups but like
you kind of find the people who tend to
think like you do or have the same Vibe
issue yeah yeah
um
I I actually like you followed me on
Instagram I know we go back and forth
and you probably see like there's a
spiritual undertone to where I'm where
I'm at in life
and um it's just the truth it's like the
cold hard truth of like what happened to
me where I fell into my artist bag truly
and why I think it's resonating on a
frequency level right that album is
called the highest guess who's on the
guess who's on the [__] biggest
highest the highest frequency in the
[__] planet it's kids you know how
many people tell me their kids [__] [__]
with it I mean I'm not making the music
for kids it's it's adult music and it's
like you could argue you probably you
couldn't some songs you shouldn't let
your kids here yeah my wifey hit me with
that sometimes tell her it's a frequency
thing
I still remember what we told her five
minutes ago she's fine yeah yeah yeah
um but you know what I'm saying like
it's it's kind of where this whole
conversation is connected and why
I stand by being like the best thing
that ever happened to me was staying
individual independent and not trading
yeah maybe I could be playing stadiums
right now if I took the Dives five years
ago or even three years ago which there
was a few times I almost did what were
those opportunities like why did you not
do it well you know get fairly I got
pretty balls deep in one in particular
where I was like very close to doing it
people know which one it is or no I've
never really said it it was with a big
artist in Tandem and it was tied to
doing that you know it was tied to
having features it was tied to being on
their tours post Malone
all right go ahead but you know
um but more so even even even deeper
than that
really what it came down to was like
when I talk about intuition I'm dead
serious like I never felt like the
people like the real administrative side
of the record labels like
I didn't value their opinion they're
like oh they're like [__] in a suit
telling me if it's a wave or not I don't
need you to tell me if it's a waiver now
I'm not even making music for you yeah I
actually prefer I don't give one [__]
what you think about my music and then
I'm just thinking about it I'm like this
is my livelihood and I'm building this
and it's just like I'm gonna gamble it
with this dude who might be at the other
company in three like it's like a
merry-go-round people are switching
labels they're getting hired so I just
like I talk about being behind the
curtain a lot and like I've taken this
really long route here where I've just
seen a bunch and I've sponged it up and
I'm like this doesn't really align with
this doesn't make sense for me you know
I mean yes
I could get way more popular and famous
but I'm giving away the Lion's Share of
my [__] income and this is my
livelihood these people don't give a
[__] I know I can sense it you know what
I mean so
that was where it really was I can't say
there was like one thing they did or one
reason but it's still wrong this
intuitive feeling like this is way too
much of a gamble like yeah you know what
I mean it reminds me of Kanye uh the
trilogy that's on Netflix uh he's got
the one scene where he goes in uh he's
got the CD and he's a producer he wants
to be a rapper he puts it he's playing
it and he goes like literally like
office to office and they're just like
yo bro like get in my office like I'm
trying to get work done right and you
hear and you're like bro that's a banger
yeah yeah now and it's like
art I mean taste is so it's so
subjective and and Society we like to
he's the best I'm the best oh you see
these streams he's the best he's sold
this many it's like
arguments over who's better and I can't
believe you like this and you know this
whole thing it's like you don't go to
dinner and argue like you should have
got the steak the steak's way better
than the chicken you should have got it
it's like it's just [__] taste you
know what I mean so for me it's like if
I like something that's my compass I
feel as though I'm tuned in to who I am
and my taste I've closed the artist Gap
there's a gap like I forget the Perth
philosopher who talks about this but
when you're creating things there's a
gap that you the real aim is they talk
about the 10 000 hours that's how you
close that Gap you have something in
your head in your heart that you want to
create it takes a lot of time a lot of
patience and a lot of diligence and hard
work to close that Gap and then be
actually creating what's in your heart
and in your head tangibly so over the
years I've closed that Gap significantly
to where right now I feel as though I've
arrived at I'm making what I want to
make what's in my heart in my head and
it's effortless and this is where I'm in
my bag here so if I [__] like it at
all there's going to be [__] hundreds
of thousands or maybe millions of people
that like it too you know do you ever
think when you see how many streams or
the views on a YouTube video or whatever
like
one of the pieces that it took me a long
time so we'd publish a YouTube video
write an interview with somebody or
something a million views like cool got
a million views I'm excited right like I
see the numbers like everybody else but
I stopped a thought one time I was like
dude you're not my Super Bowl stadiums a
million people is right like imagine
sitting on the field all these people
watching and then times have probably
eight or ten and being like whoa that's
a lot of [__] people right do you
ever do that where like the digital
numbers don't feel nearly as real as
maybe you go play a festival and there's
a thousand people and you're like yo
that thousand people feels way more real
than the million people who listen to a
song but it's just a number on on the
screen yeah yeah it's it's uh
it's kind of
this it's like
it's the times we're living in right
like
things are just going digital and that's
just the way it is right so what you
just said is super valid and I've had
that thought before
you can't ever
trade in the feeling for human
connection and the energy in a room and
and how it feels to shake their hand
look in their eye or just you walk in
and people erupt and and they're singing
the lyrics and you feel it and it makes
it all worth it you know what I mean
um at the same time you know from from
the business standpoint and just being
objective
you could really argue nowadays it's way
more cost effective as an artist and
Creator to stay home and create and
upload because you're reaching yeah you
might be in Tennessee Nashville
Tennessee and there might be 8 000
people there that night and maybe you
made three thousand new fans out of it
awesome but one post can make [__] 18
000 new fans and get in front of 600 000
new people and that whole what is that
kinetic reaction like what is the chain
of of reaction that happens there and
how does it trickle down into your
success and money earned or awareness or
notoriety you know so
I don't uh I really again leaning into
the spiritual side of things I I don't I
I'm really practicing Detachment like
the joy like
the joy I get when I have an idea and I
create it and and I have a [__] huge
smile on my face like I'm a [__]
eight-year-old you know what I mean like
I'm in my room [__] sometimes in my
underwear because I just woke up and I
gotta [__] I'm smoking a [__]
backward looking at the ocean I got here
off making music and I got a [__] I'm
lit up with a huge smile from an idea
it's kind of where it begins and ends
for me now I'm gonna execute it I'm
gonna execute it because that's the role
I've taken I've taken an independent
route and it comes with more duties I'm
gonna make sure I execute this I don't
have executive producers or anrs or
labels they're gonna I'm not interested
in spending money and marketing it and
trying to tell people like me I believe
as though like you said
you put your true frequency out there
you put your true self out there it will
attract others that are on that same
Vibe but I also think it's a more
valuable fan I think a lot about like uh
you know there's
um you could have millions and millions
of people who know you and kind of sort
of like you but by doing it the way
you're doing it when you have a million
people show up somewhere they [__]
love you like I saw a video uh recently
uh Taylor Swift I think maybe in
Philadelphia I don't know if you saw
these videos uh she did a concert and uh
they were filming like the bridge and
like the highway and [__] outside of the
stadium and somebody commented they're
like yo she's got more people outside
listening to the music than most artists
have inside at their uh show it blew me
away she's a probably the prime example
of like
yeah she's gotten mega mega famous and
has been for a long time but she's been
able to have this grounded feeling right
like she shouldn't you never lost her if
you were listening to her you never lost
Taylor to the to the east like to The
Ether of just being so famous and having
such a different life like she's still
there there's there's just something I
think there's something human
that other humans need or really yearn
for and it's subconscious but like you
could tell if I'm being authentic of
course you just can and like even your
ear can you're like I don't know why I
like this more maybe technically like a
lot I have no idea what I'm doing
musically none
I have no music theory understanding
yeah I have no [__] idea why I have
Melodies in my head I don't know you
know what I mean but
you you know someone who's classically
trained might say oh why didn't he go he
should have went to a major there why
did he I don't give a [__] you know what
I mean and I think at least I'm going
off my ear and my experience is like I
think most people aren't really they're
not listening to music like in theory
you know I mean they're just going it's
a feeling it's literally a vibration how
does it make you feel you're a Vibes
dealer exactly for real though and you
know like if you can add a Good
Vibration to someone's day or even for a
moment
that's where you start to have these
real fans like so she's done such a good
job at cultivating and amongst Mega
stardom just having a grounded essence
you know and and she's really really
good at at showing her fans she cares
she played a [__] three-hour set in
[__] rain
crazy most guys most guys with cats most
people would just be like [__] it we'll
redo it you know it doesn't matter I'm
so [__] successful and famous it
doesn't matter you know it is a
similarity between Taylor Swift playing
three hours in the rain and uh I think
Michael Jordan was famous for saying
like if I was not like basically on my
deathbed I was playing right whatever
kid bought that ticket maybe the only
time he's ever got a chance to come
watch me play I'm playing and you almost
get this like um the the people who rise
to Absolute like the extreme of uh
Talent they feel an obligation and like
they feel so um connected to the
audience that it's not a one-way street
it's not like oh you guys have all this
Fame whatever it's actually this feeling
of like I owe you all just as much as
you think that you know I like uh you
guys owe me and as much as I think I
literally fell into a spiritual bag
because I was experiencing this yeah I
had people telling me like I saved their
life with with uh you know certain songs
I would make as much as I was like the
college Rap God like I I did always kind
of tap into more meaningful stuff and
and I'm on this tour bus it's like the
[__] Magic Carpet Ride you know you
mean like we're getting we're getting
wasted plans plan shows getting wasted
going out getting more wasted whoever's
around girls on the bus fall pass out
wake up another city we're doing the
same thing you know what I mean and and
you do it over and over again and
there's something like
I don't even know how to put it it's
just kind of numbing you know what I
mean it's like then all the P it's just
like a simulation it's just new faces
and news news but it's like the same
song and dance literally you know what I
mean so but it also is like you and your
boys probably at some point get to uh
you've done it so many times you like
you could literally before the night
starts like script it out you're like
Hey we're gonna do this then he's gonna
say this to a girl right this guy's
gonna get drunk and pee on himself like
you just know we had a [__] blast I'm
not I'm and especially coming from the
space where this was so left field yep
like I had no foresight of like me being
a musician and touring and being like I
just didn't you know what I mean like I
had me being I I had a feeling I was
gonna have Fame and success in some way
but I felt it was going to be from being
a pro baseball player and that was all I
care you know that was what I wanted to
do but we go on these tours uh getting
to the point like
I started to feel myself first off we
had a blast and I'm not saying it was
that we did like it was amazing but I
started to feel a lack of presence
and what you're talking about is
you know this ability to stay present as
an artist when you are getting abnormal
amounts of attention adoration you know
what I mean you're getting almost
situations that like
you know it's not really like natural
for humans to be like for another human
to be like I come on stage and people
like ah you know what I mean like that's
not even normal or natural you know that
that becomes numb and then people are
saying these things and they're like I
was having these meet and greets I
stopped doing meet and greets like this
I came up with a new way of doing it but
it's just like I'm waiting in a line for
half the time I'm hungover and I am
truly trying to be present and they're
coming up shaking your hand and telling
their story and they have this really
short window of time and like the
security guards rushing them and it's
awkward and I'm like they're pouring
their heart out I started to realize
like
I needed to tap into presence like I
it's it's when I started to clean up my
life a little bit and really start to
practice presence because I didn't
really have much of it as a young man
you know like and that has been a huge
unlock because
as I've gotten more successful I get
more grateful more compassionate more
understanding of fans and maybe the way
they behave sometimes is a little
overbearing okay you know I mean less
self-importance as I've become more
important quote unquote in the world as
my notoriety grows
less you know judgmental and and less
like hey like give me my space I'm a
celebrity or you know it's just it's
just like for me the more popular I get
the more [__] thankful I am to the
people and it's really you know goes
hand in hand with some of my choices
here like
I'd much rather you talk about you I
know your numbers got in business and
and I have a very different approach at
how to view an audience and how to
monetize an audience and and I really
think what is the difference
so I have I have something so I call my
fan Steve's
why
no idea like most of the [__] that works
like we just talked about we're dumbass
stupid ideas me and my boys we would get
high we'd smoke and be like uh yeah go
do things Steve we just always call each
other Steve and we were filming a little
TV show I started a YouTube Vlog called
tauren's boring which was satire was
like really racy probably couldn't put
it out now you know what I mean like it
was it was like the trenches of touring
women partying whatever a TV Esquire
Network sees it we do this is Mike Stud
in 2015 or 16 I believe we're filming it
three weeks in there's a camera crew
following us and they're like the
producer pulls me a size like we have to
address the Steve thing because all we
have is you guys calling each other
Steve and like it does no one it doesn't
make any sense it's not going to make
sense to the viewer you know so we
address it it becomes a bigger thing you
know what I mean the Steve thing is is
uh it's just like a perfect anomaly
example of like I think all the best
ideas are the stupid ones imagine being
the producer going home and like telling
your significant other these [__]
guys call each other Steve like can you
imagine if I just came home and called
you Larry yeah yeah like
there was there was this boyish charm to
it all even as we were [__] idiots
and probably doing it longer than we
should have been and we weren't kids
anymore but we felt like we were I still
feel like I'm a [__] kid right now
but like
so only Steve's is something that I S
that I that I launched in about I think
it's we're approaching two years ago
right okay
obviously you know
only fans is a real thing real Commerce
happening there but also very risque
very Niche you know porn sex leaning
right like just that it's definitely
Associated to that
now I'm an artist who like really makes
a lot of ideas I freestyle everything
it's pain against the wall there's
there's a lengthy Vault a lot of great
ideas and but you know there's also a
process of executing which is like
taking songs that are 50 ideas to a
hundred right and I'm just looking at it
objectively I'm trying to understand
like I'm trying to see where the
Innovation is because it's the Wild Wild
West the industry's changing so fast and
I'm looking at where we can innovate and
we started this subscription model no
art no artists had ever done it where
it's like yo I'm literally gonna I'm
locking myself into a timeline which is
a big creative No-No like hey let
creative as an artist you're supposed
you're not supposed to timelines are
like kind of
almost like be careful to subscribe to
timelines don't put time on your
creativity and don't rush things but I
just was listening to myself and seeing
what I was doing and most the ideas
happened really quick now I have this
Vault growing
if you think about it right I'm putting
a song out every two weeks I'm doing
behind the scenes only exclusive access
you know you know the same song and
dance is like a patreon whatever
um
but I mean I'm not doing any extra work
and I've tripled my music Revenue in two
years so the way I look at audience
right
10 000 people a month subscribed to 10
bucks I'm getting 100K for ideas that
guess what
they might not come out right or they're
going to come out of most of the songs
do come out and do the same business
they would do on the spotifys and the
apples so I'm just getting a [__]
cash advance from people that really
want to care that really want to hear
this [__] and are really tapped in and
we haven't even scratched the surface
man it's been a really slow development
there's a reason why we're we're making
our own it's I can't I can't exactly say
that the the date yet but very soon here
we've been building out a platform that
is built for this the music industry is
like really really changing
um with AI and what's happening and like
it's really not about having a zillion
fans 2 million fans it's about having 20
30 20 000 people if 20 000 people are
subscribed at five to nine bucks a month
you're talking about being a millionaire
and it's only 20 000 [__] people that
are tuned in you know I mean so it's
weaponizing your actual art it's
whatever you're good at you know what I
mean this direct to Consumer model is
just to me I feel as though it's bigger
than creators it's
is Commerce you know what I mean like so
my boy who's a partner on this company
that we've been building which is why
I've been slow playing the development
of only Steve's because it's going it's
going to go a lot user friendly and a
lot better very soon
his girlfriend's a content creator she
has 70 000 followers I believe she has a
hundred people subscribed to her she was
kind of the beta of the first the first
trial 100 people subscribed she's doing
eight thousand dollars a month she's
working two hours a week and she's just
making one-of-one recipes recipe packs
no no digital there's no she doesn't
have to get on camera you know I mean
she's just leveraging her a little like
the crowd that the crowd that she's
built she's living in her passion so
she's making a living off how she lives
which is really what making a living
should be forget it for living and doing
living your truth and figuring out how
to monetize that directly so what I'm
saying is like
I already know the Commerce and how hard
it is for artists to really get
lucrative and I know how saturated this
Market's getting right now there's a
hundred thousand songs a day uploaded to
Spotify that's crazy and apple and guess
what in two three years it will be a
million a day
AI might change it forever to the point
where there's 10 000 songs going up a
[__] minute because they have ai Bots
generate you don't know what do you
think about the AI stuff I think it's
legit it's it's the future so like you
can you can
it's no doubt definitely polarizing
there are going to be a bunch of people
hence what I was just talking about
there's going to be a bunch of music
consumers that say [__] that [__] I
wanna I wanna have a connection with I
want to I want the art to be from real
artists and I love music and it's just I
can't do you know cool right so there's
going to be a bunch of people that go
that way and then there's going to be
the majority of the people that music
isn't music isn't like they're not going
on Spotify when they get home from work
and combing the [__] okay
think about you like you you have a
[__] business and then you have kids
and you you're not like combing the it's
for kids when I was in college
it's for kids every leaked album I
[__] knew about it exactly right now
exactly couldn't tell you one of them so
guess what kids and I'm telling there's
a song right now called heart on my
sleeve by a goat his name was ghost
writer and I know through a friend of a
friend that it was a it's a fair it's a
fairly established artist who did this
so first off right now the way the AI
works is I can explain it a little bit
like the way the way it works is the
artist the songwriter right you have to
create the Melodies and record them with
your voice so you have to have one to
know how the feel and the sauce to just
make a dope song So this guy who did it
is actually a dope writer right then he
runs it through the AI generated Drake
in weekend bot which sound pretty
[__] close you know and the shit's
taken off it took off immediately on
Tick Tock started to take off on Spotify
they took it down in two days but right
now as I scroll through my Instagram
reels I hear it every [__] day no one
gives a so many people don't give a [__]
who the artist does anymore yeah my
whole point with the direction and like
I started to realize it's like it's just
about having your crowd and [__]
managing that yeah serving your crowd
because very soon bro like
the artist could become obsolete the
producer could become obsolete with this
AI thing I think it's the future I think
most kids you know like we said kids are
the ones who are the combing looking for
the who's my favorite artist this I love
you know it's like art plays a big role
in kids lives and they have that free
time and
most kids who are seven eight years old
right now by the time they're 15 and
these at this AI bot is just going to
keep improving and proving you're not
gonna they're not you're not gonna know
what's real or fake yeah so they're
going to be listening should be like yo
this [__] shit's hard I don't give a
[__] who made it you know what I mean
like why don't you do uh I think Grimes
uh yeah I saw she basically I don't even
know she actually did anything no I
think all she said was have at it use my
voice I won't come after you and we'll
split the rest of the future so so what
part of what's being built in our world
it's like it's starting here in this
space there's only Steve's like you're
an artist you're a Creator maybe you're
a [__] maybe you're a mechanic who's
amazing at fixing tires and fixing cars
you can Outsource your services directly
as a Marketplace so like included in
this Marketplace like like my
marketplace right now is subscribe for
nine bucks you get a premium podcast
premium songs for those guaranteed you
know two podcasts two songs a bunch of
behind the scenes [__] we're also
kicking back cash you can create curate
your own service right but where it goes
from there is essentially it's it's a
market it's it's no different than
Shopify so on on my page or on my artist
page going forward yeah you can submit
your songs with my bot oh like just like
Grime said if I like it I'll sign off on
it you can feature me on the song I did
no work
you know and pretty soon that's just the
way the AI bot works right now pretty
soon it will be so developed to where it
will say you're a mic fan right and you
want a song with Mike I have enough
songs and offerings that the the AI the
bot will be able to predict and learn
the type of Melodies I would do as well
so not only will it
replicate my voice but it will also be
able to write the song so you could type
in lyrics and say I want a song about
[__] Chrome I can think you can do it
right now if you go into chat GPT or
whatever you can say
um for example uh yeah I know write a
blog post about this but the part that
blew my mind was you could be like and
write it in the style of Hunter S
Thompson write it in the style of
whatever amazing eventually you're just
gonna be the right song lyrics about
this topic right but I'm in the style of
mine I'm also saying melodically so oh
interesting I'm saying like oh I know
what I've heard all the mics the AI has
heard every Melody Choice I've ever made
and it predicts and interprets what I
would do melodically it's not just the
words that's putting it on there if you
don't like it you hit refresh until you
get another one
so that you know what I mean like this
is where the Commerce of of music is
going to change completely does it does
it hurt you if too much music comes out
like is there a scarcity value yeah uh
where you know okay you you definitely
publish more than most artists I would
say right and that's part of the brand
that's part of the lifestyle like all
the stuff and it's like hey when
inspiration hits I'm doing I'm not
waiting for an album whatever
could you do it too much
um how are we going to find out we're
gonna find out yeah no you know it's
it's uh
it's it's Case by case I'm a type of
artist like I said I've kind of
developed into this space creatively
where I'm like most the idea is I'm like
they're happening quick you know I mean
so yeah like I play a middle ground
right now but even you saying that it's
a bit outdated and I'm a bit out I'm in
a similar age bracket where like it's a
bit outdated that's kind of an outdated
thought like oh man you're over serving
people are [__] bored in three
seconds now yeah yeah that's true that's
true so it's like
oh that like the old model was
essentially like hey we're working this
song to radio right now like this this
is your shingle don't put out another
song hey we're working this song right
now don't put out the album because
they'll be too much there's too many
songs and now it's just like bro each
song is like buying a [__] piece of
real estate it's like a sales person
that goes out into the universe and
maybe it's gonna Garner a bunch more
business you know I mean or maybe it
won't but for a small overhead cost I
can buy a property
let's my small overhead cost because I'm
doing a lot of it myself cost me four to
five k to put out a song execute a song
and put it out right
I'm making that in the first [__] two
minutes on streams when it goes out how
much money can you make on a street like
what is like a general for an artist
whether you or something yeah I mean
this is this is where what I'm talking
about independence and like
a lot of people are bitching about and I
understand where they're coming from
like man I made 300 million streams and
it's and it's only x amount of dollars
right it like feels like because they're
looking at it from the old model first
off if my music wasn't stream capable if
it wasn't on streaming services I'm
getting right now I get monthly monthly
listeners I could I could even [__]
show you monthly listeners I think
across Spotify and apples five like 5.2
million listeners right it's a lot like
like unique people yeah unique monthly
listeners that's [__] crazy right but
at the same time like
and put that in context for people like
Taylor Swift Drake like huge huge names
how many do you think they get I'm gonna
I'm gonna just pull it up just just to
have it because because when you start
to think about not just like the number
of plays right not just the uh um kind
of views on YouTube but actually the
unique number of people right way more
important numbers 70 million for Drake
just on Spotify so it's probably over
100 million monthly listeners yeah [__]
what I'm saying is
these are different type of listeners
than the people that would go and buy
your album you know what I mean
these are different type I'll repeat it
these are different type these are
different types of listeners that would
go to a store and [__] pay 10 bucks
how to buy your album so what I'm saying
is like
yeah there's 100 million streams and
yeah you only made you know I don't know
what that it equates to you can find out
quite easily but regardless you wouldn't
have got 100 millionth of those streams
it's this ecosystem and the way music
listening and consumption has
transformed is like there's a lot of
people getting streams just by
happenstance just by people being in
playlists or an algorithmic hey I'm just
all day in the store we play this
Spotify playlist in the Stream so it
shouldn't be I'm not really one of those
artists who are a big contester of like
the payout model because but can people
make like let's say that they don't have
only Steve's like all the other stuff
can an artist be mildly popular and make
a living yes yeah yeah so it's not um
it's like I recently saw uh
um who was it I think it was Daniel uh
Cormier uh he was talking about
everyone's like you know UFC fighters
don't get paid and for sure when you
look at the numbers you're like damn you
know they made this much the fighters
made this much that don't seem very fair
but he's told the story about uh he when
he fought Jon Jones and I think got paid
like three hundred thousand dollars get
another 300 000 in sponsorships and two
days after the fight Dana White called
him up he goes hey bro we're gonna give
you an extra 400 000 our Champions need
to make a million bucks right that's not
caught in the data anywhere right and so
it's like the UFC and again I'm not
saying the UFC does that every time I'm
not saying that they should or shouldn't
it's just like I'm assuming with the
math of people say 100 million streams
equals this dollars like there's
probably other things people are doing
to make oh yeah oh yeah yeah 100 million
I'm just making sure this is the right
number I don't want to botch it I know
this is a numbers podcast
wait till he finds out we don't do
public math on here
yeah so a hundred million streams on
Spotify is about a quarter million
dollars in income
the difference is
I'm getting [__] Lion's Share I don't
have any hands in my pocket when you do
a fifth a traditional record deal that
doesn't what's 15 of 250 plus you got to
play your manager plus you bought a
house for your mom plus you have your
overhead costs your assistant plus your
producer splits
plus taxes yeah at the end of it all you
know so
you know you can like 100 million
streams is a lot you know but at the
same time like
here's what I'm saying about the whole
model that we're building right
it needs to go this way if you want to
be a human artist in the next five to
ten years you're going to have to have a
focused group of your people who [__]
with you you can constantly marketing
yourself in the digital world you know
and it's going to get more and more
digital world and then you have to be
able to bring them to this space and
understand how to monetize them and it
is this subscription model in one way or
another it is for the artist because
I've developed like I'm a bit of a
unicorn because I was just just the luck
of my timing you know what I mean like I
developed this fan base over a decade of
being truly authentic and working my ass
off and just always giving free content
to the point where now I'm comfortable
saying enough I'm gonna [__] I'm
gonna give you all a bunch more content
but at this price and and I've earned
that with them you know what I mean but
there is going to be an education
learning curve happening and it's
happening already it's just like because
other creators are doing it and making
real livings
comedians I mean there's some like
there's some comedians making huge
[__] bags and they're not talking
about it and it's this I know some of
them and they're [__] making a lot of
money and bro like I'm I'm kind of the
guinea pig yeah I know what this did bro
I'm I'm doing six figures a month okay
subscription I think it can go I really
think it can 5x in like a year or two
okay so let's say that this works like
let's take an artist who uh is on the
come up becoming more popular uh is
smart about not just staying independent
getting stream money built out a
subscription uh we haven't even talked
about you got some products and and
merch like all these other things that
you've got where there are additional
revenue streams and kind of feedback
into this right
is it possible for an independent artist
to make
I don't know a million seems actually
pretty feasible a month it is could an
artist make 10 million a month if Drake
did this right now I don't even know
would you make more or less money than
it's making more
if you said you know what I'm pulling my
[__] from all this you got to subscribe
you can hear my whole [__] catalog
and all my new [__] and I got a new
album let's drop it on there
I don't know bro I really don't know you
can maybe make 100 million in a month
bro Elon Musk got uh on Twitter I think
these guys said it like two bucks or
something uh you know the subscription
thing he's got like 25 000 people
subscribed he gets it right and and by
the way he didn't tweeted he didn't do
it like he just like literally the
Button he's just sitting on just where
like there's just this rumbling
happening it's underneath and then once
it's at the surface it just becomes the
norm it's happening though like there's
a rumbling happening and it's building
and building it's going to come to the
surface where like
The Listener is going to understand that
like yeah like this is just this is how
I support my art I support these their
their lives and that's how I make the
artist that's how I make my consumers
feel because it's the [__] truth you
know what I mean like y'all are helping
me support so I can make this music The
Way I Am if you if this music touches
you and has a role in your life the
reason I'm able to continue to do it
this way and not sell my soul or have to
do a record deal where my whole dynamic
changes and maybe the Art's never the
same which happens to a lot of artists
when everything changes you know what I
mean so it's kind of this agreement
between the consumer and you know if you
go back to like real true Commerce and
how it started is like everyone go to
the [__] farmers market and we'd
barter hey what are you good at you make
the best bread I'll give you some money
for that thank you you know like and the
baker's happy because he's doing what he
loves and this person's happy because
you know they're they're getting the
product they want you know I mean so
in the long run here I really do think
it serves the community when the
community to be in culture it's just
like yo find out where you're good at
figure out how to monetize it and guess
what like that number you're talking
about
do you know how many people how many
artists have like 2 000 people that
really [__] with their music 2000 is a
tiny number these days you know what I
mean because of streaming and the
it really gives you a ton of exposure
like to me like Spotify taking the line
shares just a tax because they're
[__] giving there's tons of there's
tons of like opportunity and just the
exposure generated from being there and
how the streams work you know what I
mean so it's like yeah like if you got 2
000 people my subscription's nine bucks
a month
you know what I mean that's a real
[__] bag we're talking about 20K a
month if I told most art like most
artists are starving um
a year they're getting [__] they're
like yo my song has two million streams
like and that's [__] nothing what is
two million streams two million streams
is like two million is uh probably like
five grand or something like that we
need you let's see I just told you we
don't do public math now you ask me
do complex math yep
yeah exactly 4 800 4 800. yeah so so two
million people consume that by the way
the audience is shocked that I was even
in the ballpark
two so let's not maybe two million
streams isn't unique two million people
let's let's call it 800 000 people heard
that song
bring it back to 20 000 people that need
to hear it and they're paying the
subscription and you're making 20
[__] bands a month that is
life-changing money for most artists bro
I know because I'm in the culture I see
like it's very hard I'm so that's why
I'm so but that's just but all you're
talking about here is just the
subscription and then if you have 2 000
people that are willing to pay you nine
bucks a month they're also willing to
buy your hat your T-shirt they want to
show up to your show they're willing to
do this they're willing to do that guess
what you can leverage it so
Stevenson Ranch this is a big part of my
business now like this one took off this
I've been doing products and [__] so
Stevenson Ranch obviously we call our
friend Steve's
um my house in La was a [__] zoo we
called it Stevenson Ranch because it was
like an Open Door Saloon door policy
like you could push the door open we let
you in you know like so we our house was
called Stevenson Ranch and then we just
I was doing merch and we were starting
to really work and I was like yo
Stevenson Ranch like we started building
out the [__] and it's like it's really
take it's really taken off has legs
we're doing seven figures so well over
seven Figures it's our second year of
doing it you know I mean but what I'm
saying is like this Marketplace idea
right right in that same Marketplace
like if you're in this club you're
getting exclusive hats you're getting
exclusive access I'm gifting every every
week I'm giving away signed hats signed
vinyls thousands of dollars so it's just
this community where it's like yeah if
I'm making six figures I'm kicking back
ten to the [__] fans every time it's
just I'm
yeah explain what you guys do because I
think we get uh five ten thousand
dollars per month you basically pick
someone yeah so we do it we do it I'm in
the process of translating into a
foundation officially because it just
makes sense economically but but you
know
I'd say since we've started we've kicked
back just to our subscriber base close
to 100K and it's anywhere from five some
days some months it's been 10 when
something really bad happened basically
what we do is make a post and we say
you know who who needs [__] help you
know I mean this month like let us know
like this week let us know we're giving
away we do it now is we give away a
couple thousand a week
and you know last last month like one of
our real fan got in a horrific car
accident nearly died we raised you know
we donated personally like eight eight
thousand to him but we raised almost 20
with my buddy who's a philanthropist but
it's just this culture of like
man these people are spending their
hard-earned money I know it's a I know
it's an ask I know they're Forward
Thinking and taking the dive with me
because this is rare like no one people
subscribe 9 10 bucks a month to Spotify
and they get all the songs in the world
I'm asking them to pay the same just to
hear mine so I understand that but I'm
offering so much service in it you know
I mean I'm really
you know again I might be a bit of a
unicorn because I'm a podcaster and we
have these clothing things that are of
value and I can add into it maybe you're
not that person maybe you're not that
type of artist and that's okay but what
I'm doing is I'm leveraging the dope
[__] that people want that we have to
offer and I'm giving it's it's all it
just feels like one big perk like yeah
I'm in for nine bucks this month which
is the [__] cost of a [__] coffee
and there's a chance I come up on 2K
there's a chance I get the bundle I'm
hearing all this new music I'm tuned
into what Mike's doing I'm hearing the
you know it's just this commodity
exchange that I think is actually closer
to fair you know what I mean where you
know the artist is kind of getting
hammered by the middleman in a lot of
situations where these fans actually
really [__] with the like it's pretty
easy for fans to feel connected to an
artist when they say when you're an
artist music's the most powerful
universal language in the world like you
don't even have to know what the [__]
words are saying there doesn't have to
be words and it can speak to you dude I
see it we have a uh uh email that I send
every single day is my opinion on
current events and financial markets or
whatever
once a week I send it for free and then
four days a week I send it to an
audience that pays it's cheaper
depending on when they buy whatever
um
the open rate is like 75 percent higher
for the pay doctors of course they're
paying for it right they're like I want
this uh and it also you're hitting them
more times and they're getting connected
and then what I noticed is those people
respond more they they engage more they
do all the stuff and I learn more from
them than I do from the larger audience
exactly right because I know he's a
serious person is a person who is uh um
gonna take the time to write this email
response back like all the things you're
saying it's not just music right it's
across Society is it's almost like this
leveling up of seriousness yeah right
these are the more serious fans yeah and
so if they're more serious you're
willing to give them more because you
know they're serious and in response
they're willing to engage more right
because they're they're reporting with
money for it it's almost it's almost one
of the more daunting things about Fame
and celebrity that [__] ruins people
like that's why most celebrities go off
the hinges it's just so hard to have so
much energy to face your way hey can you
give me this hey can you sign this uh
just non-stop whether it's you know when
you walk out of your house or whether
you open your phone and it's never
ending people telling you their story it
can be draining you know what I mean so
it's kind of the essence of like a
friend to everyone as a friend to no one
you know what I mean like I'd rather
really be with my dogs who really get
what the [__] going on or gonna either
support me give me truth honesty
um and when they can like I know for the
most part you know there can be bad
apples but I know the guys around me
want me to [__] win you know what I
mean and and at the same thing
I want the fan like I want to know who
the fans who really want me to [__]
win or and I want to play to them
because I know how small the number is
to really be a [__] millionaire and
really live off your art and live in a
peaceful state of not worrying about
going to a [__] job you don't like
and you don't care about which I think
is is really what we're dealing with
right now is there was an industrial age
we're going into an intuitive age we're
in the information age right now where
there's so much information it's got to
go back to intuition where you know like
we're kind of what we're dealing with
now are the results of an industrial age
where we indoctrinated the people of
society to be [__] employees
and that breeds unhappiness
so when the societies hits the Tipping
Point where there's too much [__]
unhappiness and there's no fulfillment
on a broad scale from a human Level
Society implodes
if you ask people what their purpose is
I think that it is shocking to
researchers people who run these studies
whatever how many people say I don't
know
right because if you think about
um you know hundreds of years ago it
basically would survive right at the end
of the day it was feed my family you
know do this do this whatever but like
you were so self-reliant that you didn't
have the ability to try to create impact
or do this it was just like I gotta make
sure the crops are here gotta make sure
my family is physically safe right we
don't freeze to death in the winter like
all these things
if you go back
um drop me the 50s 60s 70s right there
was uh people who were yeah they had a
job whatever but like the generalization
would be like you know the hippies right
it was like they were they were seeking
something higher or whatever and you
kind of follow and each kind of
generation has something different but
right now actually there's an entire
generation of people who are being
defined by the lack of purpose yeah and
it's kind of like I don't know if it's
the tick tock Instagram stuff where
you're just like Doom scrolling I don't
know if it's uh you're just going in and
you know you're sitting under
fluorescent lights all day long you're
just like yo I hope that my [__] boss
doesn't see that I took an extra 20
minute lunch break you know whatever but
just like that lack of uh purpose and
freedom and and autonomy and all this
kind of what we're speaking to kills
people that's what we're what we're
speaking to really this whole thing is
just like
we're kind of in a way society as a
whole especially in America we're kind
of experiencing what it what it feels
like to be rich
and let me explain not like rich people
like my outlook on life is like no
matter where you are it's it's all
perspective and lens so no matter where
you are there's there's going to be UPS
Downs highs lows problems to solve
issues from the heart whatever these
things that you have to navigate at for
your Human Experience you know what I
mean so
right now comparatively to what you're
talking about in the 50s and 60s where
it's about survival and just making sure
that like your wife and your kids are
like gonna stay alive and be healthy and
like have a fruitful life maybe be able
to procreate and continue the family
name now we're rich we're gluttonous we
got all the info we could talk to anyone
in the world I could watch a girl if I
[__] I'm addicted to sex I could
watch it all day you know what I mean if
I if I want like anything you know I
mean so we're so gluttonous that it
feels it almost breeds this feeling of
like you're constantly looking outside
of yourself to just constantly
distracted everything external like that
that her and it's like no one is getting
in tune with himself that's why I'm so
high on the spirituality I'm not
religious per se but I know what it did
to me when I went inward I don't go out
anymore bro like you got me out of the
house because I respect you I don't
leave my [__] house like yeah because
I know it's all within me I also think I
mean it's like um there's an easy life
right so uh people got very upset when I
said this but whatever I said and I
believe it is that uh if you spend hours
of your day scrolling on your phone you
have the easiest [__] life ever yeah
right because uh it goes online a lot I
don't know if you saw a 50 Cent
um uh viral video where he was like
depression is a luxury yeah and people
were like yo like that's that's out of
balance you're not allowed to say that
right he's like no you guys are
understood right he's like I'm not
saying depression is not real he's just
saying where I came from no one had time
to think about that [__] he's like
because they had three jobs they were
trying to eat right and he's like that's
not good bad whatever it's just like
it's a luxury when you look at it from
that perspective same thing with like
the Doom scrolling if you're if you go
in your phone go in the settings and
look at how much time spent all these
[__] apps if you're on Instagram for
two hours a day you got a soft life
exactly right it's not wrong no it's
just not even 150 years ago we're now
just like our parents were indoctrinated
a
ring the bell go to work that's what
school was like yes we had to create
employees they were indoctrinated into
this why they don't understand how we're
working in the information age it's the
same thing you know I mean now the new
set of certain what I meant by like
we're all kind of rich like we're rich
with info and access and correct you
know what I mean so it's like yeah and
it's like what rich people deal with
like I Know Rich Kids who were born rich
and they're [__] because they don't
you know I mean they've always had the
access it's never gone anywhere there
was almost nothing nowhere to go you
know what I mean and it was a part of me
like coming into some some financial
success and also achieving some goals
like
I went into the spiritual aspect of my
life like I told you I felt like I was
losing presence and I had things that I
yearned for and it didn't [__] mean
anything you know what I mean and like
that's what I mean I don't want to sound
like chasing the ghost I don't want to
sound like a hippie about it but like
that's what I mean by going inward is
just like take some time because
we're indoctrinated to [__] be
comparing ourselves yeah we're
indoctrinated to be looking outside
because there's always something to see
so that's why I limit myself and I limit
my access going outside I limit my I
have timers on my phone like no more
yeah because I'll find myself in a less
grateful more anxious oh should I go
somewhere maybe I could go to dinner
tonight and we should go to [__]
Papi's Steakhouse and like I don't give
a [__] about that [__] you know I mean
but if you're out if you're [__]
watching it oh looks good steak looks
good they're celebrities it would be
cool to be there you know and it's just
like you know this purpose discussion is
it's really becoming bigger and bigger
and like you said it's a it's a
it's alarming how many people feel as
though they don't because the purpose is
being here yeah you know I mean the
purpose is being here and just trying to
manage navigating your Human Experience
manage now be here now the purpose will
reveal itself but who's to say your
purpose isn't just being here and maybe
impacting your wife's life positively
your kids like what is bigger than that
when you walk out the room what do your
boys say about you what's bigger than
that it's because everyone else we want
more you know what I mean because we're
looking at everybody else and all the
things they have and all the highlights
you know if our parents grew up in this
age they'd be going through the same
[__] thing you know what I mean
they're jealous uh yeah I could talk to
you for hours where can we send you
there's a bunch of people who probably
are watching this or listening to this
uh they love the story they love kind of
how you guys are innovating in the
business I've never heard the music
before so maybe where can we send people
if they want to listen yeah I mean I'm
I'm that douchebag that has one a very
very strange artist name it's literally
Mike so I so I went from an incredibly
douchey name Mike Stud and even somehow
got douche here and just went Mike
but you know Mike's no you'll be more
wild than Mike Stud Mike yeah Mike Stud
was like I literally I didn't I didn't
think I was going to be a musician yeah
and I'll give it just cool we'll end on
this like my uh I went to Duke do you
remember the Duke lacrosse scandal yes I
remember I went there right in the heels
of that I went to high school I grew up
in Raleigh North Carolina and so I was
in high school all that was going on I
don't know you were from Raleigh and for
people who don't know uh the Duke
lacrosse scandal was probably one of the
most controversial things in that part
of the country yeah for 18 months here I
come trotting in with my [__]
backpack thinking it's gonna you know
and oh here's the Duke athlete I made it
to Duke like I made you know and then
like they're on almost like a lockdown
so they don't allow us to have social
media at that time I'm I'm dating myself
I'm aging myself here I think they only
had Facebook and Twitter was just
started this was yeah 2010 or something
like that whatever whatever it was so we
all came up our coach was a hard ass and
he's like yo no social media like
essentially what they were doing was
like they were trapping Duke athletes
online like they'd have a pretty girl
and like friend request you that you'd
accept her friend request and then it
would be somebody trying to smear Duke
athletes so like underage Drinkers and
stuff and it was just they were
attacking Duke athletes for a period of
time when we got we first got there so
we all came up with fake uh Facebook
name so we could have it still and our
theme was porn star names with our real
initials so mine was the number I had
the best one on the team it was Mike
Stud and like I was like so that
actually stuck as a nickname to my
teammates and it was like we hated our
coach he was a [__] [__] so they
would we would always call each other by
our code names and he wouldn't know what
was going on you know what I mean so
that's why Mike's stud existed when I
made a song I was just a Duke baseball
player and that's that was the obvious
name to go with I didn't want to use my
real name I didn't think I was going to
be an artist anyways we got off track
but that's an incredible story yeah so
so then it works and it was like man I
don't even know if it would have worked
without the name I think the name was a
big part of it it was like polarizing
you hated it or you loved it as I as I
matured and then this became real and
real and real and then I also understood
there was a ceiling I was I was in the
game and taking these meetings there was
a ceiling to being Mike Stud because he
was the college douchey athlete oh isn't
that that college picture oh yeah it's
cool like no one wanted to take it there
was a ceiling there so the Rebrand my
business people at the time were like
you're crazy like this is making money
like changing names right now you might
you could go to zero you know and I just
knew like I knew it couldn't be my stud
I knew the music I was making was
different I knew who I was becoming I
was a man Mike Stud would be a lie to be
that still you know so I changed it to
Mike period
um the period is just like very
significant it's one to differentiate it
a little bit because Mike's like the
most common [__] name ever but also
you know the end is this is the end of
the story it was Mike sander the
baseball player there's Mike Stud the
you know college rapper and Mike the
creative entrepreneur you know figure
out a way of navigating bringing this
into my adult life you know but
um really long-winded answer long-winded
answer well if uh if you can own the
name Mike pretty good spot to be yeah so
so social media it's it's at just Mike
j-u-s-t-m-i-k-e because everyone says
mike who and he says just Mike you know
I mean everyone I see it all the time
like what's your artist name like my
like what you know it's just Mike so I
thought about I thought about being my
artist named Jess Mike but then I
thought it would be better it's just
it's better like yeah 100
um if you want to just listen to the
music you just go to any of the
streaming platforms just type in Mike
period
or Mike I think will just pop up you
know all right thank you for doing this
we'll double duty again in the future
yeah for sure it's great to meet you man
this is a blast